deep within the waters of Mexico's
Yucatan Peninsula is a cavern called oil
negra the name means black hole which is
fitting because it is a lightless void
about the size of a professional
basketball arena when the region was dry
before about 10,000 years ago a sinkhole
that fed into oil may grow swallowed up
a collection of saber-toothed cats giant
ground sloths mammoths and even a young
girl the human skeletons slight build
relatively wide pelvis and incomplete
tooth development indicated that it came
from a 15 to 16 year old girl who the
divers name nya which means water nymph
analysis of the girls skeleton revealed
that she stood four feet ten inches tall
radiocarbon dating of one of nice teeth
and analyses of calcite deposits that
formed on her bones after she fell into
the cave suggested that the youth had
lived 12,000 to 13,000 years ago in
March 2014 divers on the research team
returned to retrieve nya skull and four
additional bones like other ancient
American skulls knives facial features
differ from those of modern Native
Americans but analysis of DNA from one
of her teeth shows that the girl carried
in Asian derived set of gene variants
previously found only in North and South
America the analysis also shows that the
ancient youth and modern Native
Americans share a genetic profile that
probably evolved between twenty six
thousand and eighteen thousand years ago
the results appear May sixteenth in
science